what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing on with fear
itself and here was a deal with fear
itself I kind of want to talk about this
for a second because there's a couple
things that I feel like we need to
explain looking at the comments of the
previous videos with some of the
questions you guys had first and
foremost fear itself was one of these
stories that was designed to rework
things Marvel still had a lot of things
that had been held over from the Joe
casada era of his whole idea of pushing
things and making a new direction so
essentially everything from like
Avengers disassembled running all the
way up to really the heroic age running
all the way up to Dark Reign so over the
span of about seven years or so there
were a lot of things that had happened a
lot of chairs a lot of status quo
changes The Avengers were disbanded they
were replaced by the New Avengers 98% of
the mutant population lost their powers
there are a lot of things that went on
in Marvel at the time one of the most
notable things was the death of Captain
America and we'll talk more about that
here in a second but what this story was
designed to do in a lot of ways was to
take a lot of those threads that have
kind of been left hanging those pots or
isms just sort of been dangling all this
time and essentially wrapped them up to
basically tie up loose ends now not all
of them were tied up and in fact the
ones that weren't tied up were designed
or were left that way for the purpose of
telling future stories later on down the
line for example you know the formation
of stark resilient which would come
later on different things like that but
the idea here is that we initially pick
up with with Captain America facing off
against you know the forces of sin and
really what kind of passes for Hydra but
not really but again this is not like
Steve Rogers Captain America this is
Bucky Barnes Captain America now the
reason why I feel like that needs to be
explained is because one I don't think I
explained that in the first or second
video and two this this event fear
itself actually wraps that up so when
Captain America died after the events of
Civil War
and following that Iron Man I'm pretty
sure it's iron man takes Captain
America's uniform and gives it to Bucky
Barnes and so Bucky Barnes becomes the
new Captain America and his arrival was
met with a kind of a it was a mixed
reaction some of the the old guard who
really really really wanted Steve Rogers
to stay and there were some who were the
old guard that wanted steve rogers to go
and then of course there were new fans
who wanted to see steve rogers stay in
the world fans who are I guess new fans
who wanted to see him go he was really
kind of a mixed bag of people who wanted
to see different things but in any event
Steve Rogers had come back about a year
before this story took place he came
back 2009-2010 summer
somewhere along those lines and it was
of course the Captain America reborn
storyline where you found out he was
time displaced they basically pulled a
Batman from Final Crisis but then once
he made his return there was a one shot
follow-up and it was basically the
question of who's going to wear the
shield who's gonna have Captain America
shield is it going to be Bucky or is it
going to be Steve Rogers and what this
did is it allowed Marvel to spin Steve
Rogers out into a whole nother series
called Secret Avengers and Secret
Avengers basically serve the purpose of
having like a black ops team for the
Avengers group but that's that's the
team that Steve Rogers largely led and
that was this whole thing what this does
is it basically removes Bucky Barnes
from the mantle and it brings Steve
Rogers back but at the moment right now
with this initial charge going into
going into the US Capitol it really is
Bucky Barnes leading the team now
switching over to Asgard this was well
this was this is an interesting
situation because this again deals with
hid Loki and that's one of the things
that goes on here when it comes to the
event of fear itself it was a little bit
different from a lot of the other
crossover events that you saw in this
sense that journey into mystery was
designed to provide the back end for why
it was Loki was doing what he was doing
in the main story itself whereas in a
lot of the events that go on sometimes
especially like when it came like secret
Empire for example the tie-ins are
wholly separated from the main story
itself and so you'll have like the
beginning of the of the event you know
of like secret Empire for example and
then it'll split off into tie-ins and
the tie ins will show what characters
are doing and then they'll wrap back
into the main event at the end and so
unless you've been reading the tie-ins
you have no idea how that character got
to where they work with this it's
totally different
fear itself was designed to be kind of
like a new age of storytelling when it
comes to crossover events it was
basically this idea of like the main
story gives you all you need and you
don't really need anything else but you
go read Civil War and it's it's woefully
incomplete if you don't read the Manor
if you don't read the tie-ins nothing
really seems to make sense and so it's
it's one of those interesting scenarios
but nonetheless kid Loki showing up here
is basically for the purposes of
breaking Thor out of prison what kid
Loki's been doing so far has basically
been trying to sow revolution and within
the Asgardian landscape the problem with
this is that under under most normal
circumstances people may have been
inclined to side with him if it wasn't
him if it wasn't Loki if it was Thor
people would follow him they would it
would basically be Thor leading a revolt
against Odin which is it really summing
Thor would do but with kid Loki he
definitely would
this is that again kid Loki's got the
reputation of Loki and so everybody
would look at what he's saying and
essentially coming along and being like
look Odin's kind of lost his mind we've
got to find a way to stand out to him we
have to go back to earth and we have to
protect it they would look at it as some
kind of ruse and so nobody really
trusted Loki and so at this moment it's
just kind of coming along and saying
okay look we've got a free Thor like we
got to get Thor out of here and get Thor
back to earth and so in the interim what
this does is it picks up with really
this kind of calamity across the board
and the sensitive Zuri man basically has
the powers of Thor The Incredible Hulk
now has the powers of Thor I mean it's
it's all these crazy situations and it
responds to the Incredible Hulk what
this ends up doing is bringing in like
Carol Danvers Spider Woman Jessica drew
which I don't even know why she's there
here's a funny thing
so Jessica drew has the ability to emit
pheromones that will not really have
this the exact same effect as purple man
she can't really dominate the Wills of
others but she can make them fall in
love with her now she tried it on
Wolverine I thought myself in Salik
comment pop we're having the school
conversation I called him up but we
ended up getting it like heated up
talking about Jessica drew about Spider
Woman and he's like well Spider Woman
tried her pheromones on wool rain and
all it did was make him dizzy
so people with healing factors can
combat it but they're not like totally
immune to it but Incredible Hulk who
would have to be the same way but keep
in mind this Thor halt for lack of a
better word is basically like mindless
savage Hulk but bent for a particular
purpose but all these people who were
picking who are willing these hammers
are all driven by fear that's the
important thing to bear in mind here and
the reason why is that when we switch
over to the Fantastic Four with the
hammer having landed an onion C Street
in New York the Fantastic Four were one
of the first people to respond and to
investigate I remember while all this is
going on the world is going to pop like
everybody else is dealing with a zillion
different things but when the Fantastic
Four chimed into the Avengers and say
hey look we're investigating things then
that means you leave the Fantastic Four
to their devices and so with Ben Grimm
showing up the hammer starts talking to
him he starts hearing voices emanating
from him and when he goes to pick it up
of course
he's transformed into a mindless Beast
itself and just starts ripping
everything to pieces so again every
single person that gets one of these
hammers is driven by fear and serves the
purpose of sowing chaos that's basically
what this is and the reason why is
because the serpent feeds on fear so so
long as those around him are feeling
fear he'll continue to grow stronger and
end you know basically gained more and
more power now for Thor himself
where he's freed by Loki and basically
meets with SIF and the warriors 3 the
idea of physically standing against Odin
of leaving Odin's Odin's
traveling to Midgard it amounts to
harassing this is a very dangerous game
they're playing
because while Odin wouldn't necessarily
kill him Odin would certainly like he
could banish them from Asgard he could
make them mortal like send them away
the Odin forces is capable of doing all
manner of different things again it's a
very dangerous game that they're playing
here and this game is discovered when
Odin shows up now this is kind of a
funny thing here this is really sort of
feeding on the old nature of the Thor
comics the historical you know
publication history of Thor comics as
opposed to what we would expect with
Odin having previously locked up Thor
and Loki breaking him out and then
coming into the situation where Thor's
basically been freed and he's talking of
revolt against Odin it's not really like
Thor's talking a revolt in the sense of
leading the armies of Asgard against
Odin himself
it's basically Odin walking into his son
and his friends talking about abandoning
Odin's view and travelling back to
Midgard and at this point it's one of
those things worse like a father and a
son sons always get a lot more leeway
with father says it's just the way it is
because it's their offspring you know
parents are a lot more leaning with his
and so instead of like casting Thor at
prison instead of making him mortal or
something like that he says fine then
you will you'll have your quest if what
you want to do is go to earth and fight
among the people who are who are there
then do that now a lot of this stems
from the fact that Odin knows how
stubborn Thor is if the word says this
is what I want to do I want to go to
earth and I want to fight alongside the
Earthlings because I feel more kin to
them than I do to you
then Odin's gonna be like fine because
there's no talking Thor out of it and so
ultimately Odin cast him out sends him
back to earth gives him his hammer and
says here you'll need this but you've
got a time frame once the Serpent's
power rises like once he gets to the
point where he's all-powerful where he
seizes control of Earth then one of two
things is gonna happen either I'm gonna
bring you back or I'm gonna let you die
but regardless of what fate it is you've
brought it on yourself and so again it's
kind of a cool thing because switching
back to Captain America and the capital
with him Falcon Black Widow facing off
against sin with all this new power it's
interesting because one of the things to
bear in mind is that when it comes to
Marvel when it comes to the stories like
this oftentimes they kind of seem to
stretch the limits of credulity and they
don't really seem to make sense and the
reason why is because you're dealing
with someone with a formidable amount of
power both in strength speed durability
as well as the power she wields by
virtue of her hammer and would easily be
able to crush Black Widow Falcon and
Captain America and so the question you
would probably ask is why are these the
ones fighting well in reality the
Avengers were never relieved they never
really consisted of the most
beings in Marvel in Marvel Comics that
was really reserved more for the x-men
The Avengers were mostly just like the
bravest people you know they'll run
headlong into their own deaths but
they'll run headlong no aside from The
Incredible Hulk Thor the Avengers
usually consist of mid-range to some of
the weakest characters in the Marvel
Universe
it means Captain America what the hell
can Captain America do he can punch
really hard and run fast and throw a
shield he's not ultra strong he can't
you know control the elements I mean he
can't do any of that cool stuff the
x-men can where some people will say the
x-men are kind of broken which they are
sidetracked
think about that for a second all right
so among the mutant population you've
got Franklin Richards kind of depending
on who's right in the story sometimes
he's a result of the cosmic control rod
which is basically Galactus his power
the power cosmic from the negative zone
or he's a mutant all right you've got
storm who's pretty much Omega level why
the hell haven't they confirmed it you
got Magneto you've got Emma Frost you've
got Matthew Malloy oh you have like all
these super powerful Omega level
characters who were just broken as hell
like do the x-men are so broken somebody
make an argument in the comment section
somebody create an argument and tell me
why the x-men are not Opie and broken if
you can make a convincing argument I
will give you a rock or ring so moving
on from our little rant our little
diatribe of course sin takes it to
Captain America and that's the important
thing to remember Captain America is
kind of like the leader of the group
right like he's like the moral support
if you take him down then every most
everybody else will lose their moral
backbone she ends up ripping off the arm
of of Bucky Barnes plunges a staph right
through his chest and it essentially
seems to kill him and that's really the
end of him like that's the end of Bucky
Barnes you know at this point he's just
kind of like look you have to tell
everyone this serpent is is literally
the person behind this because at the
moment they haven't known the the
Avengers haven't really known who's
behind this all they've known is that
these artifacts which they learned we're
hammers had crash-landed on earth
different people had picked them up
they've gained insane levels of power
and they just been attacking cities by
having contact with the hammer itself
he's learned the hammer secrets and the
hammer secrets are that it's basically
the serpent who's behind all this
who's waging a war against earth and
eventually seeks to set his sights on
Asgard and retake the throne but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb dwarf you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later
purse
[Music]